recently scientists have discovered that  neutrophils can solve complicated maize  neutrophils are the key cells that  protects us from bacteria  neutrophil can literally chase the  bacteria and engulf these bacteria but  chasing these bacteria in a complicated  tissue environment is not at all easy  how does neutrophil overcome this hurdle  scientists give neutrophils complicated  maize and watch them navigating through  these complicated maze they found out  neutrophil take the shortest route to  reach their destination  and the fact that they choose the  shortest route is dependent on the  concentration gradient of several  chemokines they follow the gradient of  chemokines to reach their destination  and thereby they kill the pathogen and  save us that's one minute see you next  video